bright green and with a distinctive
high-pitched squawk the ring-necked
parakeets has become a common citing any
parts of britain but his numbers have
grown so to have some eyebrow raising
tales of how they first came to these
shores many claimed a flock escaped from
the london film set of the 1950s
Humphrey Bogart and Katharine Hepburn
film the African Queen
rock legend Jimi Hendrix who released
two pet birds in Carnaby Street in the
late 60s is even a suggestion that the
group causes several that escaped during
a burglary at George Michaels Hampstead
home in the 1990s to see if any of these
tales have wings a team of academics has
been using police techniques to try to
locate the original source to be able to
say that Jimi Hendrix he was the one
that released the parakeets into London
towards the UK and it's just not the
case we found multiple sources there's
multiple bits of evidence that say there
was a parakeet released here or there's
a source here there's a source here all
over the sort of South East of England
it's most likely that these guys have
escaped from Averys they've been
released or there was a bit of a panic
over a psittacosis and parrot flew that
that people have actually released them
deliberately Kensington Gardens here in
the centre of London has become a known
hotspot for parakeet sightings hundreds
of people come here throughout the year
trying to catch a glimpse of the new
tropical residents in the less than
tropical climate and when foods involved
they're not hard to find the bird lovers
here have all heard the stories before
quite like passing them on to intrigue
tourists colour is so surprising and and
startling when you see it that green is
a green that you don't really see in
kind of the palette of British birds or
even of trees and plants in this country
so I think people are often reaching for
the more outlandish version of the story
of where they came from now had once
been talk of a parakeet cull but that's
no longer on the table partly because
there's just so many of them it seems
these beautiful creatures are here to
stay even if their family story is
slightly less colorful than many would
have you believe
get Bradshaw skynews